the analogy I love to use is everyone is
familiar with Google Maps and driving
with Google Maps or ways when you drive
with your smartphone as your google map
finder it's sharing your location in
your speed and where you are so that's
pretty private data but would you give
up your Google map for the traffic for
not sharing that information probably
not and if you think about the future of
healthcare hopefully it is a bit of a
Google map or ways for healthcare we're
all sharing some of our data and
hopefully a private secure anonymize way
and can get that map back of our health
trajectory because you know Alan's
health trajectory and risks and
prevention and therefore mine just like
we're driving different cars and then we
might get the opportunity to choose to
choose and to share and hopefully maybe
even be rewarded for sharing there are
companies now that are enabling you to
hopefully maintain and store your
medical data in the blockchain and they
get rewarded for sharing it in separate
their other companies now that are
collecting data from any and and and
sharing that and making money from it
sometimes famous story from last week's
Strava a great company for tracking your
bikes biking and exercise their data
could be mapped and you can now map what
people working out now let's find a map
someone running around Stanford
University playing there now you can see
where maps sort of the military might be
running around and places the world
where so there's a lot of potential
Darkseid's downsides but also tremendous
potential if we can unleash the power of
data and I'm a firm believer many in the
healthcare field that patients should
own their own data have access to it but
and also be able to share it in smart
way